So, the question is,
how powerful is morphology?
And like most questions in life,
the answer is what I have to always
tell my kids, kids, it depends.
If you have nice, clean binary images,
or even, I shouldn't say that.
If your binary images behave exactly the
way the three or four binary images you
looked at when you designed the system
were behaving, then things will be fine.
So clean might be the wrong word.
If it's well, here it says almost clean.
Let, let's just say that your binary
images are, sort of, well-behaved.
So here's an example and, again, this
comes from Linda Shapiro, all right?
Here is an original binary image, and,
if I ask you to look at that quickly and
ask you where are the faults in those
gears, you would have to look for
it at a long,
look at it for a long time.
But if I show you this picture, and I
say, where are the faults in the gears?
You would say, oh, I guess there's
one here, and there's one there, and
now when you look at it you see,
yeah, there really is,
there's a tooth missing from the gear.
So the question is,
how did they do that?
So again, I'm not going to
into too much of the detail,
I'm just going to show
you this set of images.
It's all on one page,
that's the sequence of operations, and
i'll just describe them briefly, okay?
So, here was their original
picture that i showed you.
Basically over here,
they were looking for places that had
a ring that would be essentially
black like this, white out here.
And remember I was telling you
about don't care pixels, you know,
don't care in there and, and, and of
a particular shape, particular size, and
the only pixels that
lit up were these guys.
Okay?
All right?
Well that's fine, and then you say okay,
I'm going to take those and
I'm just going to dilate them
by something called a hole mask,
which is just this basic shape.
All right?
So you realize what you end up
with is just the holes filled up.
Well, if I, or
this plus this, I get that.
So voila,
I have filled the holes of my gear.
Okay, great.
Then what I can do is I can essentially
do the same trick again of removing
pixels that basically have with
a structuring element like that.
So I find every place where a
structuring element like that fits, and
that will rem, that will be able to
pull out these, these middle parts.
And then I can dilate the edge, and
I end up with this thing
that looks like that.
Great.
That's sort of a bound around the edge
that's thicker than the edge.
If I and these two things, so
it's an and, I get just the teeth, okay?
That's what's shown there.
And, and also, you'll all notice we're
starting to see there's that gap
right there, because that's where
the teeth are missing, all right?
Well, what I can do is I can
dilate that by something that
has the size of the tip.
And if I run that around here,
I end up filling everything except
where that gap is, both here and there.
And then given those, I can do,
in fact the result is just a,
it's got this thing called defect queue.
That's just this little round ball,
basically the operation's
exactly as it is here.
It's b 7 right, minus b 9 here,
dilated by the defect queue, or
back with b 9 and I get this, okay?
So, would I expect you to
implement something like that?
I, I don't know.
The point is that with
these relatively simple,
low level mathematical operations, you
can do a relatively sophisticated shape
analysis if you have
the particular shape that you,
if you know the particular shape
that you want to deal with, and
the particular types of defect sizes,
for example, you wanted to find.
So, there are other
operations that you can do.
Here's a, just a list of things
that you might computer.
These are shape descriptors
of binary blobs.
And, like I said, this used to be a very
important part of computer vision,
especially in assembly or
machine vision of inspecting 2D parts.
And for those particular applications,
it still is.